oh hi it is cold out there i mean really
cold and the game life studio is in
california so i i can't even imagine
what it's like for the rest of you
suckers if you can even watch this video
from inside of your igloo okay it is not
weather for going outside it's time to
sit on the couch pull on a snuggie and
enjoy a nice lengthy adventure game then
you're in luck this week's new games are
gonna keep you occupied until the spring
fall
if you're a fan of japanese role-playing
games and the animation house studio
ghibli well actually that venn diagram
is probably more like a regular circle
isn't it well so you'll love this week's
release of nino cooney it's an rpg
developed by level 5 with characters and
animated sequences by ghibli that's
right this is a team up of the people
who brought you dragon quest 9 and
princess mononoke
ninokuni has gorgeous graphics and
amazing music and the japanese version
got rave reviews the english
localization is excellent and you can
even listen to the original japanese
voices if you want as you play through
this playstation 3 adventure
if you're more into american style
adventure games check this out ron
gilbert the creator of monkey island has
teamed up with double fine to bring us
the cave a brand new puzzle game in the
style of maniac mansion or maybe the
lost vikings you control a team of
misfits you have to get through a cave
full of traps and puzzles and only by
carefully combining their different
abilities can you progress and figure
out what the heck is in this cave anyway
the best part is the cave is available
for download on pretty much every
platform 360 ps3 wii u pc mac even linux
for goodness sake so you have no excuse
and finally as you know if you've been
watching game life every single week
bioshock infinite is coming out on march
26th of this year but chris you might
say to me if we were on speaking terms
what about if i haven't played bioshock
one and two well first of all you don't
really need to play bioshock one and two
to enjoy infinite and second of all what
the hell is wrong with you bioshock one
and two are like two of the greatest
games the generation what do you mean
you haven't played them yet ah well
anyway for you people 2k games is
releasing bioshock ultimate rapture
edition it's 30 bucks it has bioshock 1
and 2 and all of the downloadable
content plus extra bonus features so
even if you're already a fan of bioshock
you might even want to buy this just for
the extras but if you haven't played
these games this is your moment to play
catch up alright so get on it you
slackers and we'll check back with you
next week on your progress